the 290 meter long stricken Cruiser the
cost of Concordia has lain here for 19
months now the attempt at removing it in
one piece is set to begin in earnest but
it's an unprecedented and risky
technical challenge and there are other
factors too if the weather conditions
permit will start the operation at 6
a.m. on Monday the plan is to use
hydraulic pumps and cables to lift the
partially submerged wreck off the island
of Giglio to an upright position that
part of the salvage operation alone
could take up to 12 hours the second
stage envisages a set of giant steel
containers being welded to the wreck
they would help to refloat the Concordia
before it is total pot but ever since
running aground the ship's hull has been
sinking lower and lower into the sea the
salvage team will only have one attempt
at stabilizing the vessel the shipping
operator estimates the cost of salvaging
the Concordia at around 600 million
euros there's no guarantee of success
the ship could break apart at any time
further threatening the environment and
permanently sinking the dreams of the
salvage team